well everybody welcome to another Python
tutorial this tutorials me discussing
how to calculate percent change this is
actually a highly debated topic amongst
accountants and the like so you know
it's an exciting it's just gonna be so
awesome
so let's go ahead and get into it the
calculation of percent change for the
most part is a relatively easy
calculation although not only do people
disagree with the denominator at times
they also disagree with the version of
that denominators at other times so
let's go ahead and just hop into it the
formula that we'll be using and that a
lot of people use with percent changes
new - the old divided by the old times
100 now you will find some people that
are going to give you new - the old
divided by the new times 100 now what's
the purpose for percent change well
generally you have two major purposes
for a percent change that I see a lot
the first one is going to be to
calculate some sort of profit and so
like you'll say like you know I weave or
growth right so if you're new my steal
divided by the old times a hundred will
tell you how much growth you had in
terms of where you came from to where
you are now so I think a good example
for something like this would be like
say you started at $80 and now you have
$100 well 20 out of 80 is a quarter
right so it's it's 25% so from 80 to 100
you grew 25% rights your starting point
was 80 but some people want to say new -
the old divided by the new or a percent
change and that would only that would be
really 20 out of a hundred so really
they're they're saying you only grew 20%
I don't understand that why you would do
that but that is with how some people
calculate it that will not be how organ
it's gonna be new - the old bottle by
the old times 100 now the other thing
that comes into question is when old is
a negative number so say you were so it
comes into question a lot whenever
companies like a lot of companies lose
money for a quarter and then the next
quarter they gain come are the game
money and the question is how do we
calculate a percent change of that so
I'll show you in a second how that
affects things now you wouldn't think
that percent change is such a highly
debated topic but it actually is so
sorry
to start the tutorial out with that but
they just have to make you aware that
you might have to fight people on how
you how you calculate percent change
anyway I'm a nerd so a sample we're just
going to make a sample bit of data we'll
just make it just anything you could
type it with me or you can just make it
up on it's five six one three six three
two and that's there some negatives in
there a negative five negative 19
negative five again to zero one six
so that's just like some sample data now
let's define a percent change function
so let's say define percent change and
then we're gonna have two parameters
we're gonna have the start point so
whoever in this starts and then the
current point this brings me to another
point I only discussed the first reason
people might use percent change the
second reason people might use percent
change is to normalize a line so like if
you're comparing two let's say companies
you can compare them by percent growth
instead of maybe revenue growth right so
instead of comparing them by dollars you
can compare them by percent change then
you can chart them on the exact same
chart and you can really compare them
very easily so that's another reason why
people would use percent change it's
just a way to normalize a line very
simply so percent change start point the
current point what's the percent
difference so what we're going to do is
have this function really only be one
line and it's going to return the float
of whatever the current point is
- the start point so this is new - the
old right and then we're gonna go
divided by the old and we're gonna throw
some absolute value bars around it so
start point then when we're all done we
multiply it by 100 now just for the
record we want to say float here just in
case so here we're using all whole
numbers and Python does not naturally
divide into a floating point decimal it
would automatically just divide into
whole numbers if you don't start with
some sort of floating point so that's
what we're doing we're just kind of
forcing it to use you know typical
division so anyway so new - the so new -
the old divided by the old times 100
point zero zero again cool so now what
we want to do now that we've defined
this percent change function we're just
gonna say for each and for like each
number in sample PC for a percent change
equals percent change and then where is
our starting point right the first
parameter is start point well that's
just that's easy that sample zero and
where is the current point well each end
and then when we're all done let's go
ahead and do this we'll say we'll print
each end and then we'll print like these
little bars here so we can divide it or
see like the difference and then PC so
cool so let's save that and let's go
ahead and run that and look at the
output so here's the output that we've
got so obviously the first number
there's no percent change right from 5
to 5 and then from 5 to 6 you've got a
20% change from 5 to 1 you've got a
negative 80 percent change from 5 to 3
negative 40 percent change and so on now
the next question is what was I talking
about before with you know the absolute
value so let's just take away the
absolute value so we'll just this'll be
it'll be pasted right below this one so
it won't really matter so let's take
away the absolute value and see what
happens you'll see there's no change
and there's no change because this did
not like the five right the five that
we're dividing by so what happens is
when you divide by a negative what
mathematics does but when you go from
you know five to all of these numbers
including a negative it can't it
computes you know the negative correctly
well let's say you actually went from
let's make five a negative five let's
return the absolute value for now let's
run that and let's see so we started
from negative five and we went to six I
would call that a positive movement and
I assume you guys would too and we are
indeed returned a positive two hundred
twenty percent then as we kind of
decline a little bit to five now it's
only a one twenty percent now we go back
up to three 166 to twenty below the law
then we get to negative five no doubt a
zero percent change negative nineteen
well now we've actually lost and we
actually have a negative okay I think
you guys get it so now let's take away
the absolute value bars and do the
typical percent change calculation now
we can see from a negative five to a
positive six we have a quote-unquote
negative to twenty percent movement as
if we lost something then we get you
know the negative nineteen and suddenly
we've got a positive change right so
this is kind of why it matters what your
actual goal is right so if you wanted to
make the movement from a negative 5 to a
6 in theory you you could get there by
doing negative five minus a negative
number and that would give you a plus
and you can move forward and so you know
you and kind of see how this negative
220 is is appearing but at the same time
that's not actually the result that
we're looking for especially if we
either looking to measure growth or even
decline right so from a negative five to
a negative nineteen that would be called
a decline right or really I guess if
your this would be fine if you're
measuring too
line right in 280 percent change in your
decline or growth in your decline but
you're trying to measure growth really
this was a backwards movement right from
negative 5 to negative 19 this should be
a negative and then same thing if you're
trying to normalize lines and compare
two different lines gosh if one line is
starting with a negative 5 or a negative
at all you're in trouble you're gonna
have a really hard time normalizing all
kinds so that's why I throw in the
absolute values there it just makes more
sense to meet logically so every time
I've ever used a percent change I'm
actually looking either in normalized
line or you either normalized for
comparison or actually measure some sort
of growth so that's that's why I think
you should throw in the absolute value
bars anyway
something tells me no one else is gonna
care that I did that but felt like I
better defend it so anyways hopefully
you guys learned something new as always
thanks for watching thanks for the
support of the subscriptions and until
next time